>>> THIS JUS IN.
CHIEF JUSTICE JO ROBERTSHAIRMAN
CNN'BRG INTO
ALL  THIS.L USOR, WOLF
ROBERTS COMINGOWHAWE HAVNEW INF
HARLAN CROW, THAT MEDO
HAVE AW,E BEFORECE THOMAS DIT IM
CLN A ,
REPUBLICAN MON
INEST. CNN H LED
CNN'S ARIAN DEVOGE A BINs D JUS
ELF FR
CONFLICT OF INTESTAN
JUST MAKES THEOLORDS SHOW THAT E
GHTECHECL
SUPREM DTI PARY CALLEDC IN
LIMITED PA
ILAN CROW'S
NOT APN A CAPT THE DIEN  HOLDIN
TIME, NOTRE MICRNTTHE STATEMENS
CASIL
REINDEPEW HO
EN TT
HAVE KNOWLEDGE OF OR INVOLVEMEN
DISCUSSED THISY OTHER CA
WITH A JUSTICE.
AL, ED
TO HEATHTH.
ODO NCERNED.>> WHEN U N ENTITY
WHO'S GIN S OFAVTIME
WE'R WHOLLY OWNED BSIAA CONTROI
N' PASKINDS OF ISSUETHAPPEARANC.
>> Reporter:ENRTS BYINVESTIVWS I
THOMAS AND H WE GINNY
ACCEPTED AND GIFLA FOR DECES.
AND THATD
ERTIESDISCLO THE REAL
RPOHE WASL AND NGS.
IEVES HE WILL D HIFING REAL
CONFLICT OF INTEREST WITH BELEA.
2017, A COLO PROPERTY, THESWOR
E NEIL GORSUCHS ARLY $2 MILLIONH
GORSUCH DISCLOSED  OPERTY IN
FILINGS.
BUT THE SECTION LISTING E
BUYER WAEME COURT NOENTATIVES F
TO CNN'RE
FOR COMMENT ON T
JUIC
THT FIRM BOUGHT
GOH' SAY NEVER
ARGUED ANY
DECLINED TO COMMENT  C
O
AND AS WE'VET REPORTED CHIEFE JO